ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้า
สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียน
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนรูปฟ้าวันนี้วันอะไรคะ
วันนี้วันอังคารค่ะ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 16
เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
สิงหาคม
ปีพตตปีพ.ศ
ปีคศปีคศ 2  022 หากค่ะเมื่อวานนี้วัน
อะไรคะเมื่อวานนี้วันจันทร์วันที่เท่า
ไหร่คะวันที่ 15
อา
เดรียน
เดือนสิงหาคมปีพตตปีพ.ศ
ปีคศ
ปีค.ศ
2002  2 ค่ะค่ะพรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะพรุ่ง
นี้วันพุธ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
17 เดือน
เดือน
สิงหาคมปีพตตปีพ.ศ
ปีคศปีข้อ
2022 ค่ะค่ะตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะครูฟ้า
ตอนนี้เวลา
10:00 น 10 โมงกี่นาที 4
42 นาทีค่ะสุด
10:42 นาทีนะคะครูฟ้า
อะไรคะคนอื่นแล้วใช่ไหมคะกูพัดตื่นแล้ว
ค่ะผู้หญิงตื่นแล้วนะตื่นแล้วเอาหินตื่น
แล้วรู้แล้วค่ะรู้แล้ววันนี้นะผู้หญิงก็
มีเกมมาเล่นกับครูฟ้าอีกแล้วมีเกมอีกแล้ว
หรอผู้หญิงเกมอะไร
เกมในวันนี้นะคะผู้หญิงก็จะมี
ให้ครูฟ้าเนี่ยเลือก 2 อย่าง
คือ
เลือกสองอย่าง
อะไรหอยหา
ไม่มีสอยครูฟ้าต้องเลือกก่อน
ครูฝาเลือกเสร็จแล้วครูหญิงก็จะบอกว่าจะ
ให้ครูฟ้าทำอะไร
จะ
ได้หาผู้หญิงกูว่าต้องเลือกก่อนเนาะค่ะ
อย่างแรกเนี่ยคู่ฟ้าจะเลือกบอกแล้วอันนี้
ก็บอกบอกฟ้าใช่ไหม
กูฟ้าเนี่ยบอกนะบอกพูดออกใกล้พูด
แต่ต้องพูดความจริงนะ
ความจริงอ่ะเนี้ยอันที่ 1 บอกก็คือให้พูด
ความจริง
โกหกแต่โกหกไม่ได้บอกก็คือพูดความจริง
แต่ถ้าคุณค้า
อย่างที่สองอย่างที่ 1 เนี่ยบอกอย่างที่ 2
ก็คือทำครูหญิงครูฟ้าไม่ต้องบอกแต่กูมา
ต้องทำคุยอาจจะให้ครูฟ้าเต้น
อาจจะให้ครูฟ้าถอดเสื้อไม่ได้เนาะปิ้งไม่
เนื้อหาไม่ได้แล้วฟ้าหักหูอาจใช้ตัวฟ้าลบ
ลิปสติก
Nars ครูฟ้าก็จะต้องเลือกว่าจะเลือก
บอกหรือทำ
เลือกอะไรนะคะเรื่องอะไรเนี่ยบอกหรือทำ
อ่ะอย่างแรกอ่ะครูฟ้าเรื่องเสร็จแล้วนะ
บอกเนี่ยมันก็จะมีคำถาม
มีทั้งหมด 1  2  3  4  5  5  6  6  7  8
ทำเนี่ยก็มี 1  2
3  4  4  5  5  6  7  8 เหมือนกันรู้ว่า
เลือกสมุทรครูฟ้าเลือกบอกหูฟังหรือหลัก
ว่ากูฟ้าอยากจะได้คำคำถามข้อที่เท่าไหร่
ยังอาจ
เพิ่มโอเคเลือก
แบบค่ะผู้หญิง
คำบางหนาคนไม่มีหัว
นะเกลือหวยอ่ะแล้วครูฟ้าจะเลือกคำถามข้อ
ที่เท่าไหร่คะ
ว่าเลือกคำถามข้อที่สองค่ะต่อสองถึงจะ
กากบาทหนา
ตายทำตามข้อที่ 2
ข้อที่สองเนี่ยถามว่ามา
เวลาตอนดึกๆนะตอนดึกๆก็อาจจะมาบานตั้งแต่
11:00 นจนถึงประมาณตี 1
ตอนดึกๆเนี่ยนะคะครูฟ้าเนี่ยเคย
จะลงมา
เปิดตู้เย็นหาอะไรกินไหม
จะนอนแล้วก็แบบมันหิวอ่ะมันหิวก็เลยล่ะ
คุณหน่อยมันแล้วก็เลยเดินลงมาแล้วก็เปิด
ร้านนี้เป็นตู้เย็นอาจจะมีโค้กแป๊บซี่
เค้กมา
หา
เฮ้ยลงมาเปิดตู้เย็นไหม
เธอเคยทุกวันค่ะคือผู้หญิง
ผู้หญิงเราจะถามเลยว่าเคยเนี่ยบ่อยแค่ไหน
ตอนนี้ไม่ไหวแล้วเมื่อก่อนนะคะเมื่อก่อน
นะครูฟ้าเคยอ่ะเคยลงมาเปิดตู้เย็นตอนกลาง
คืนคือว่าฟ้าเนี่ยนอนใช่ไหมกูว่านอนอ่า
แน่
นอนอา
ซ้อนอนประมาณ
ตีสุทัน
ตี 2 แล้วกูไปหิวตอนไหนคะ
เปิดตู้เย็น
ก็เลยจะชอบไปกิน
หน้ากินอะไรตอนประมาณเที่ยงคืนต่อว่าเดิน
ไปข้างล่างนะคะแล้วก็เปิดตู้เย็นเนาะกู
ว่าจะเดินลงไปแล้วก็ดูว่าในตู้เย็นเนี่ย
มีเค้ก
มีอาหารมีอะไรกินหรือเปล่า
ก็เลยชอบลงไปเปิดตู้เย็นหาอะไรกินหาอะไร
กินนั่นแหละก็มาก็เคยหักผู้หญิงเฮ้ยลงไป
เปิดตู้เย็นตอนกลางคืนบ่ดูหนังโอเคอ่ะบอก
มี 9 ข้อขอโทษค่ะอ่ะข้อที่สองครูฟ้าจะ
เลือกบอกหรือทำ
ทำทำทำข้อที่เท่าไหร่
ที่ 1 เอาที่ 1 เลยเหรอคะเพราะที่ 1 เลย
ค่ะคุณหญิงข้อที่ 1 ก็คือ
ให้ครูฟ้าร้องเพลงชาติไทย
เราไฟ
อเมริกาใช่ไหมเวลาอเมริกาเนี่ยก็มีฟุตบอล
ก็คืออเมริกันฟุตบอล Super  Bowl แข่งก็
จะมีนักร้องเนี่ยมาร้องเพลงชาติอเมริกา
ทุกคนก็จะเอามือแตะที่หัวใจใช่ไหม Ozone
เดะเพลงชาติอเมริกาแต่ว่าทำให้ครูฟ้าออก
มาเนี่ยร้องเพลงชาติไทย
เพลงของประเทศไทย
ร้องนั้นเดินปากโอเคค่ะ
ลองๆ
ประเทศไทยรวมเลือดเนื้อชาติเชื้อทางมี
เป็นประชารัฐไผทของไทยทุกส่วนอยู่ดำรงคง
ไว้ได้ทั้งรู้ว่าอ้วนร้องไห้ตอน
นวลโดยไทยดุ
ร้องเพลงชาติไทยเป็นมั้ยดูๆๆ
ใบสมัครอีกไทยนี้รักสงบแต่ถึงรบไม่ขลาด a
ก็ลาจะไม่ให้ใครข่มขี่สละเลือดทุกหยาด
เป็นชาติพลีเถลิง
ประเทศชาติไทยทวีมีชัยชัยโยก็
เก่งเพราะมากหรอกมาขอมาเพราะมากกว่าผู้
หญิงร้องเพลง Justin  Bieber อีกค่ะ
กูว่าคิดดำเพลงชาติไทยไม่ได้นะไม่ได้ร้อง
นานแล้วนะพี่สาวเก่งมากค่ะข้อต่อไปครูฟ้า
จะเลือกบอกหรือทำให้มันไม่น่ากลัวหรอกทำ
บอกพักนึงก็ออกข้อที่เท่าไหร่คะบอกข้อที่
5 เพราะที่ 5 เหรอเฮ้ยหายไปแล้วนะครับขอ
ที่ 5 ขอให้ครูฟ้าข้อที่ห้านะคะ
ให้ครูฟ้าบอกของของที่ครูบาสเคยซื้อแล้ว
ก็แบบแพงที่สุดที่ภูผาเคยซื้อคืออะไรของ
ที่แพงที่สุดที่ครูฝาเคยซื้ออ่ะ
อ่าของชีพแพงที่สุดที่ครูฟ้าเคยซื้อก็คือ
อะไรคะ
โจ๊กคือ
ซื้อเองคนที่เอง
iPhone ค่ะโทรศัพท์ไอโฟนราคาเท่าไหร่
ราคาระมาณ 40000  5,000 บาท
โอโห้
แผงของคอมพิวเตอร์หรือกูฟ้าแพง
คอมพิวเตอร์อีกค่ะเพราะว่าไฟฟ้าซื้อมัน
บอกว่าใหม่ๆฮัลโหล
iPhone  2  Pro  Max น่ะค่ะ iPhone  2
โปรแม็กนะคะแล้วก็
น้องบีเรียกว่า GB  256  GB มันก็เลย
รักษาแพงก็จะประมาณ 45,000 บาททางไปว่าจะ
บานเงินนี่ก็
เพลงๆมากนะฮะแอลมาแต่กูฟ้าโทรศัพท์ฟ้าพัง
น้ำพุค่ะมีโทรศัพท์ iPhone  XR เนอะ xs
นะ xs  xs นา iPhone  10 หน้าแล้วมันก็
พังมันก็เลยต้องซื้อ iPhone  12
ก็ยืมเงิน 4,000 บาท
นี่คือ
ของที่แพงที่สุดที่ครูฟ้าซื้อเองถ้าใช่
ของที่ราคาแพงที่สุดที่ครูฟ้าซื้อหากผู้
หญิงมีเองเข้าต่อไปครูฟ้าจะเลือกอะไรจะ
บอกหรือว่าจะทำ
น้องอีกห้องนึงอันบอกบอกว่าจะเลือกบอก
อย่างเดียวก็ได้แล้วแต่กูฟ้าข้อที่เท่า
ไหร่ก็บอกมี 9 ข้อนะบอกมี 9 ก็โทษก่อน
เถอะก็เอาข้อที่ 9 ค่ะข้อที่ 9 ก็ที่ 9
สวัสดิกอ้าวเนี่ยฟ้าน่าจะชอบนะคะอ่ะข้อ
ที่ 9 เนี่ยนะคะ
ใครครูฟ้าเนี่ย
คลิปคิดชื่อเล่น
ใหม่ให้ครูหญิงผู้หญิงเนี่ยชื่อเล่นชื่อ
หญิงใช่ไหมหญิงคู่ฟ้าชื่อเล่นชื่อฟ้าแต่ง
ผู้หญิงใจกูฟ้าคิดชื่อเล่นใหม่ไม่เอาหญิง
หญิงแหละไม่เอาเบื่อแล้ว
จะเปลี่ยนเป็นอะไรครูมาจะให้กูหญิงชื่อ
เล่นใหม่จากหญิงเปลี่ยนเป็นอะไร
อุบายจะเปลี่ยนชื่อครูหญิงเป็น
นิทานอ่ะค่ะชื่อเล่น
รีโมทแอร์
ขอ
นิทาน
นิทานเนี่ยเป็นมินนี่วันที่ส่งให้หนูใช่
นิทราชายนิทราก็คือนอนเป็นมิสนอนนะคะ
Sleeping  Beauty นักเรียนชื่อเป็นอะไร
คือเจ้าหญิงนิทา
หรือว่าออร่ากันนะเพราะว่านอนเหมือนกัน
เหลือเกินมาอะจะเปลี่ยนชื่อเล่นครูหญิงนะ
ฝั่งหญิงเปลี่ยนเป็นนิทราน่ะนอนหญิงชอบ
ร้อย
เออนี่ไงชื่อเล่นอ่ะต่อไป
จะเรียกอะไรคะคู่ฟ้าจะบอกหรือทำ
ทำก็ได้หะเลือกทำ
ทำข้อที่เท่าไหร่
ข้อที่ 5
ตอนที่ 5
หัว
ข้อที่ 5 เนี่ยให้ครูฟ้าเนี่ยตอนที่ 5 นะ
คะให้ครูฟ้าเนี่ย
ข้อต่อไปทอดเดี๋ยวข้อต่อไปนับเวลาครู
ฟาสเลนข้อต่อไปนะว่ามันเป็นธรรมจากข้อที่
5 ข้อที่ 5 คือให้ครูฟ้าเนี่ยทำตัวเป็น
หุ่นยนต์
นักเรียนเถอะ
สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าค่ะรุ่น
ครูบาจะต้องทำตัวเป็นหุ่นยนต์เล่นข้อต่อ
ไปอ่ะข้อต่อไปครูฟ้าจะบอกหรือทำต้องเป็น
หุ่นยนต์แล้วนะ
บอก
ชอบ
ฉันอยู่แล้วไม่เห็นไงบอก
ก็
บอกข้อที่เท่าไหร่
พ่อที่ 8
5 ข้อที่ 8 ข้อที่ 8 นะข้อที่ 8 ก็คือ
ถามว่า
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยวันเกิดครูฟ้าใช้วันเกิดกู
ป่าววันที่เท่าไหร่นะไปที่ที่ไหนคะสิบห้า
สิบห้าพันวาคมค่ะแต่ 15 ธันวาคมเนี่ยวัน
เกิดครูฟ้าใช่ไหมก็จะเวลาวันเกิดนะก็จะมี
เค้กของมาแล้วก็มีเทียนแล้วก็มีคนร้อง
เพลง
งั้นพี่หมื่น day  to  you เนี่ยครูฟ้า
ชอบไหมเวลามีคนร้องเพลงแฮปปี้เบิร์ธเดย์
ให้ครูฟ้าในวันเกิด
ชอบหรือไม่ชอบอ่ะ
เฮ้ยเฮ้ยคุณโยต้าอ้าวคุณเยอะเลิกไง
เออเลยเหรอกำลังคิดผู้หญิงถือเค้กมา Happy
Birthday  To  You ทุกคนเยอะๆนักเรียน
เราก็ร้องเพลงวันเกิดให้ครูฟ้าครูบ้านชอบ
ไหม
ชอบ
ชอบค่ะชอบเหรอคะทำไมชอบเพราะว่าคือฟ้าชอบ
วันเกิดค่ะก็มีเค้ก
ครูฟ้าเป็นหุ่นยนต์ร้องเพลง
แฮปปี้เบิร์ธเดย์สิคะ
ประเทศไทยรวมเลือดเนื้อเธออันนี้
ปี้เบิร์ดเดย์ไม่ใช่กระเทศไทยปี Birthday
To  You  Happy  Birthday  To  You
Happy  Birthday  Happy  Birthday  Happy
โอ้โห้เยอะเลยอ่ะขึ้นยนต์ค้างโอเคข้อต่อ
ไปรูปพาสจะให้บอกหรือทำ
ทำก็ได้อาจถามน้ำ
ทำข้อที่เท่าไหร่คะ
ข้อที่ 2
ขอที่ 2
ข้อที่สองครูฟ้า
ผู้หญิงขอยกข้อที่ 1 ขึ้นไปนิดนึงนะคะข้อ
นี้ 2 เนี่ย
อันนี้อะไรคะฟ้า
อยากตอบแนวแต่ไม่รู้มันไม่เอาอะไรแมว
แว้วข้อที่สองนิ้วให้คุยฟ้าเนี่ยคำหน้า
เหมือนแมว
หน้าเหมือนแมวเป็นยังไงไอ้
หน้าแมวกูฟ้าที่บ้านมีแมวใช่ไหมแม่มาดู
กันว่ายังไงไม่เอาไว้ข้างใน
ไม่เอาไอ้หนูส่งหน้าเหอะ
ใจเอ้อ
นิยายเห็นไหมฟ้าจะทำเบื่อพ่อบ้านครูฟ้ามี
แล้วอ่ะอีก 1 ข้อข้อสุดท้ายครูฟ้าจะเลือก
บอกหรือทำ
ครูปารืคบอกค่ะ
บอกข้อที่เท่าไหร่คะข้อที่ที่ 4
ข้อชิด 4
ข้อที่ 4 เนี่ยครูให้ครูฟ้าบอกว่า
คุณอณิภูฟ้าใช่ไหมครูฟ้ามีพ่อแล้วก็แม่
อันนี้นะคุณแม่นะคะอ่ะก็ได้ 4 เนี่ยคุณ
แม่ครูฟ้า
ทำอาหาร
อร่อยไหม
ก็ไม่คิดงานแสง
กูมากำลังคิดว่ากูฟ้าเป็นคนที่กินอะไร
ง่ายๆหรือเปล่านะคะมันก็เลยอร่อย
โซโลคุณแม่ทำอาหารอร่อยไหม
คือ
ไม่บอกไม่ได้นะต้องบอกอร่อยหรือไปไม่
อร่อย
มันดีชอยซ์อื่นนะแบบเฉยๆ
คือมันไว้มันอร่อยค่ะนักเรียนเพราะว่าคุณ
แม่ฟ้าทำอาหารเค็ม
เต็มลูกที่ใส่เกลือใช่มั้ยใครดูเยอะๆนัก
เรียนลองคิดว่านักเรียนกินเฟรนฟรายชีสขอ
เป็นไฟล์นะจะมีเกลือใช่ไหมก็ใส่เกลือเยอะ
มันจะเค็มเออคุณแม่ความทำอาหารเค็มมากค่ะ
เค็มมที่สุดแต่กูพาชอบกินเค็มไงก็เลย
อร่อยเลยอร่อยค่ะ
นั่นแหละอาฟ่าตอบคุณแม่ทำอาหารอร่อยนะ
ครับว่าเข็มแต่ก็คู่ฟ้าให้ฮัลโหลเฮ้ย
อร่อยค่ะอร่อยๆ
อร่อย
คุณแม่กูฟ้าทำอาหารอร่อยค่ะคือหญิง
โอเคข้อสุดท้ายค่ะ
เลือกให้เลือกอะไรให้ครูฟ้าทำทำอะไร
เว็บไปนะคะให้จบคลิปไปด้วยให้ครูฟ้า
นั่งนิ่งๆ
ก็ยังไม่นิ่งและอยู่ด้วยเลยค่ะพี่พูดก็
ได้นะแต่ต้องนิ่งยิ่งห้ามขยับนิ่งๆโอเค
ค่ะนักเรียนคลิปวีดีโอนี้แล้วก็มาเล่นเกม
กับกูฟ้าเนาะบอกหรือทำใช่ไหมคะครูฟ้าใช่
ค่ะพี่แล้วเดี๋ยวเรามาเที่ยวไหนใดใน
วีดีโอหน้านะคะสวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีค่ะนัก
เรียนไทย